[Musique]
je
c'est bon le mot amour en appellera
bachir casting ne mâche ça bonjour
magané merci d'être là j'étais très
contente de vous accueillez un merci
beaucoup
donc je vais vous parler du film juste
une vie au réalisateur ce qu'il a
vraiment voulu mettre en avant c'est
tous ces talents qui n'avaient jamais
fait de cinéma et les mettre avec des
comédiens confirmés comme leïla bekhti
qui est guillaume canet parce qu'en fait
vous êtes prédestiné pour le rôle de
karima elle est tiraillée entre sa vie
professionnelle et sa vie sentimentale
le réalisateur merzouk meshkini il a
réalisé un écureuil
voilà ça mange pas que des glands il ya
un papillon sa mairie de foix est aussi
sorti il a pour réaliser le jazz cameron
titanic il est pas là
pourquoi parce qu'il s'est rendu compte
que sa présence pouvait un peu
déstabilisé les comédiens donc je crois
que vous avez reçu magali chez vous un
petit extrait d'un scénario
moi je fais la réplique qu'elle des
nouvelles de renzo medici très bien lire
au fils de
tu le détache tropez de type
propédeutique propédeutique
propédeutique robes et les tic super tu
sais très bien que de voir mes
impressions d'année et prometic de
succès bah c'est super merci c est ce
que tu entends ce qu'on est en train de
faire d ok donc pas faire un petit
exercice de diction est en fait vous
allez répété la phrase la casquette kaki
à la culotte picole la casquette kaki et
vous allez le faire de plus en plus vite
oui on y va aller la casquette kaki à la
culotte qui regardez moi magalie cacchia
la culotte qui colle la casquette kaki à
l'accueil du fpi qui comme la casquette
kaki avec une optique folle super
maintenant on va rentrer dans une impro
pur
ok ce que je veux c'est que vous
laissiez libre cours à votre imagination
je veux plus voir magali bertin la star
de télé donc là je vais vous demander de
dire une phrase avec plusieurs émotions
différents la phrase c'est les haricots
ça me fais péter o'leary quoi ça me
répéter mais vous allez moi rigoler tout
à l'heure regardez écoutez moi en guerre
et moi vous allez me dire étonné est
arrivé ça fait péter maintenant on est
en colère
à la mêlée vous avez dit non vous
rigolez mais non mais non mais bien sûr
mais il ainsi par exemple dans votre eau
le karine à vous êtes en colère
comment elle et karima cantal en colère
c'est moi on est plus forts d'ambitions
mais évidemment parce que vous savez les
castings ne savait pas ce qu'on va
demander une fois dans un casting et
faire la machine à laver essorage
mais si mc est maintenant un jeune de
banlieue divague ouais carrément suis
d'accord mais là vous êtes en train de
faire magali qui fait la racaille
c'est pas ça que je veux qu'ils
encourent à kayes et quel but oui on
reste là dessus je voudrais que vous
fassiez le chat il a combien de patates
ok donc chaque aucun frottez vous à moi
bah merci c'est gentil maintenant karim
à un moment donné elle va tomber sous le
charme du comédien qui s'appelle faire
tout est en fait vous avez complètement
sous son charme c'est un bel effet mais
tout ça pour vous aider il ya un
comédien qui va rentrer il faut être
sympa c'est de vous dire que ça ouais
bonjour voila j'ai des prêtres
[Musique]
dc une porte et voilà et d'un seul coup
voilà
au milieu de la pièce ils voulaient tous
avec vous baiser mais vous plaît vous
commencé à danser pour les réductions
tout ça déboule plaisait rapprochez vous
en sera chaude soyez dans la séduction
magali soyez dans la séduction
[Musique]
google attend mariage sans ces scripts s
arrêter la musique l'art et la musique
art est à la musique ce fardeau tu peux
sortir s'il vous plaît merci me magali
lacroix joué le jeu dans sa voiture
messi mais ces salles on s'en fout de
lui c'était pas lui qu'un nul c'est vous
c'est vous quatre masques non mais moi
je suis pas karim mais en vélib et
relationnelles vous êtes là même les
jeunes u fait franchement c'est de pire
casting que j'ai passé mais arrêtez
d'enfin magali savent depuis tout à
l'heure je suis dans la bienveillance
vous n'avez pas arrêté de rien qu'est-ce
que j'ai fait moi pour vous aider à
pénaliser la poule avec lui bien que
déjà la plus touchée magali si vous
voulez vous êtes venu là pour être casté
je vous avais envie d'avaler quelques
uns mais qui alourdira pervers sur soi
et sur 16e journée a fermé et alors
c'est surtout son rôle de 6 700 alors
que son rôle moi j'ai fait mais j'ai
grever droit ok on fait rentrer phares
tout vous allez refaire une danse et
vous plaît soyez dans drôles
[ __ ] faire tout cas merde je veux un
vrai une vraie scène de baiser j'ai eu
de la gale h
mais jamais de la vie au cinéma c'est
comme si je m'en vais vous donner un
conseil
la concentration je vais vous ghanouchi
on met rendement j'étais ben bella
thorne et attendez pas à un baiser à
baiser un baiser de cinéma mais pas la
langue n'avait versé le mordu m'en
approche fois on se remet là on essaye
de se concentrer
on se dit si vous n'êtes pas là pour
faire ça j'en ai marre j'en ai marre ce
qui allait du groupe est maintenant
faire un film en fait je m'en balance
il ya un moment donné congé de respecter
les gens sur quoi vous a pas respecté
magali en quoi vous apparaissez
j'entends depuis thaler on se casse tout
de suite non mais ça va pas bien c'est
un scandale contre les marges mais t'as
vu comment tu lui parles de vie est
quand même très vite fermer bientôt tu
as tous formés
mézil
vous aimez ou 20 ouais ouais mais bon
ils n'ont pas demandé ça est ce que vous
voulez voir le réalisateur m'agace
beaucoup lance je ne vais pas me répéter
demain c'est pas possible pas de geste
maladroit ce jour l'américain pareil en
amérique il suffit pas de geste
maladroit
[Applaudissements]
ça y est
de mouse
lieberman est bon